j'aime beaucoup johnny avec savez et
aimez comme en otage en le menaçant
suivaient ce bon ça une berge voudrais
le dire j'adore toutes vos chansons moi
petit mari alors il a voulu qu'on équipe
franchement elle se prend pour une
grande chanteuse sur la tête de ma mère
elle croit qu'elle a une voix off voile
fait des vocalises dans les langes et
déborah voilà exactement et al reem à
contador
alors quelle est votre chanson préférée
chanter là allusion vous écoute on va
voir gilbert va nous dire si vous
trouvez qu'elle a un beau grain de voix
dit la vérité
ben ah ok donc cdu c'est mignon allez-y
haras on aura reconnu on n'est pas peu
qu'on consomme à la bassée laquelle de
ces d'union pour que tu m'aimes encore
apparemment il ya un message privé à
l'auteur isolé sur la tête de ma mère
on dirait qu'on dit bien calés devant
nous
donc là si tu l'entends porte ailleurs
même si édenté danse d'autres danses
c'est nul
quand le croire dans les flammes je
touchais très ça m'a foutu comme on
néglige mercier va encore essayer par
copie on n'est pas encore au niveau
horaires d'été